So a few weeks ago I posted this photo with the caption,
"When you have five cats to feed."
And everyone went insane.
[siren sounds]
So a few of you guys are aware, my cat Ghost went missing last October.
And unfortunately, no, she has not come back.
I have accumulated a lot of tips and tricks
over the last five months in trying to find her and get her back to my home
So I figured it would be great to make a video about that where all of that information is consolidated
just in case you're missing a fur baby yourself.
Now, Ghost was a kitty who would wait by the front door and, like, any time it opened she would just dash out.
So I have used a lot of these tips to bring her back again and again
But, unfortunately, when I left for Peru last October she just like never came back.
That said, if you're in the area of your missing kitty
you can still use these to try to bring them home.
One: First things first, put clean water and food right outside of your door.
As well as a shelter box, especially if you live in an area that's very cold or rainy.
And in that shelter box you'll want to put a dirty piece of laundry or their favorite blanket
Because cats are very scent oriented, if they've lost their way
hopefully they'll pick up that scent and be able to find their way home.
Two:  Walk the perimeter of your neighborhood with some dirty laundry.
Because cats are so scent oriented this will help them find their way back home
If they have a favorite toy that makes a noise or a treat bag, shake that as well
When I used to do my perimeter walks
I would actually put up missing posters
just in case some of my neighbors saw her while she was roaming.
Make sure to also alert places like Nextdoor, which is Facebook for your neighborhood,
local shelters, vets, hospitals, and also your microchipping company.
And if your cat is not microchipped,
please, please, please do this as soon as possible when you find them.
Often when a cat is caught and brought to a shelter or the pound,
people will immediately scan them to see who they belong to.
and if your cat isn't microchipped, that could be all the difference in finding him or her.
And finally, don't lose hope.
Some people have had their cat show up years after they went missing
Sometimes your cat is just off having an adventure
and doesn't want to come home just yet.
And if you've seen my cat by chance,
please, please hit me up and let me know
because I miss her very much.
Thank you so much to Simon's Cat for collaborating on today's video
If you guys have not seen Simon's Cat please check out their channel.
They're amazing animations, and have been some of the most quality content on this site since forever.
And I know for cat ladies like myself and cat daddies like you out there
It is something that brightens my day.
All right, I'm Anna Akana
Goodbye.
(forever)